the position is almost repeating itself
right now he's struggling he's got
around 11 seconds and okay he made the
correct move yeah the he almost stopped
on the wrong Square he goes Bishop E8
and now the bishop protects at A4 PA if
the knight move G5 drops hikaro he has
no time left he's got to move make a
move 4 seconds aaru he panics and puts
the Knight and loses upon but now it
should be a relatively straightforward
win that being said the evaluation bar
moves another check wow this is crazy
they've only got one second incr each
move he needs to move he needs to speed
up and both players are so nervous
they're living on that increment right
now the pawn A4 is defended the white
king is going towards the queen side A5
is going to drop yeah white is winning
white will win that a pawn it's an Pawn
that promotes on a light Square as well
wh's Bishop holding everything this is
simple oh and Nakamura he gets up he
resigns not ABD satov he reacts he knows
he's done it he takes down the world
number three in the armag